two circles with radius 7 and 19 have a
distance between their centers of 22.
the circles intersect at points p and Q
what is the length of PQ
so we have circles A and B that
intersect at a common chord PQ
split the diagram into half so that half
the distance is equal to H then focus on
one triangle the radii have lengths of 7
and 19 and a b is equal to 22 so we can
say this is X and the other distance is
22 minus X
now from one triangle we solve for H
squared and in the other triangle we'll
also solve for H squared we set these
two equations equal to each other and we
solve that X is equal to 43 over 11.
from here we substitute back in and then
solve for H but finally we need to solve
for PQ which is 2H that gives the answer
of 8 root 255 over 11.